si je vous dis conquête spatiale vous
pensez à l'urss avec spoutnik ou aux
états unis avec les premiers pas sur la
lune mais saviez vous que la chine est
aussi un acteur incontournable
tout commence catimini en 1970 avec le
lancement autonome d'un satellite
il a été lancé le 24 avril 60 disent
exactement mais nous avons une image me
informations au fil des ans alors que
l'urss les états unis et l'europe
enchaîne les prouesses
la chine progresse dans son coin sans
l'aide d'aucun autre pays
sous le regard quelque peu hautain de
l'occident leur équipement
scientifiquement tout à fait excellent
même si les apparences crête
temps en temps un sourire pour un
européen disant pour des pros des gens
qui comme nous sommes très attachés aux
échos aux apparences de la technologie
mais en 2003 la chine envoie pour la
première fois un taïkonaute dans
l'espace un taïkonaute c'est un
spationaute chinois mais la traduction
littérale et hommes du grand vide
la chine pourrait devenir à partir de
demain le troisième pays à avoir réalisé
après l'union soviétique les états unis
un vol spatial habité
les spationautes chinois sont prêts à
partir leur vaisseau doit s'envoler
demain après 14 tours du monde en 21h le
taïkonautes atterri sans encombre
célébré comme un héros en tant que
chinoise je suis fière et contente car
nous sommes enfin capable de monter dans
l'espace sans dépendre des autres
en 2005 deux taïkonautes sont envoyés
dans l'espace
mais la vraie prouesse c'était en 2008
pour la première fois un chinois sortait
de sa capsule un moment hautement
politique pour toute la nation
les chinois retiennent leur souffle
devant les images retransmises en direct
par la télévision nationale
ça y est il s'est extrait le colonel
saye kong vient de devenir le premier
chinois flotter dans l'espace quotidien
dont on est très fier parce qu'on est
toujours que notre pays est arriérée
mais regardez là on est dans les avants
outsider la chine est aujourd'hui devenu
un des principaux acteurs de la conquête
spatiale
l' empire du milieu veut d'ailleurs
participé activement nouveau défi le
tourisme spatial avec le projet d'une
navette à propulsion nucléaire d'ici
[Musique]